I have a clip for you today that is one
of the most dangerous Clips I can
remember ever playing on this program
and the reason it's dangerous isn't
because the person in the video Candace
Owens
is uniquely dangerous herself there's if
you go on the New York subway platform
right as as I often do you see unhinged
people saying wacky things they're
yelling them sometimes they're yelling
at no one but they're not dangerous
because no one's paying attention to
them if the crazy Subway guy
I don't mean that Jared guy from Subway
the commercials I mean the New York
subway if the crazy New York Subway guy
had a million people following them on
social media and 150 or 200 or 300
people paying to hear them speak we
would say wow that Subway guy is really
dangerous that's the case with Candace
Owens in this clip now remember Candace
Owens falsely claimed that the comedian
Bob Saget probably died from the coveted
backs vaccine he died from a hit to the
Head okay here she is saying she
believes they
they
intentionally killed people in hospitals
during covet
and people clap and people nod and
people agree
well I'm a big believer that they
intentionally kill people in hospitals
during covet they wouldn't now who is
they okay so let's take let's pretend
that this these claims were subjected to
actual standards first is Candace who is
they is it the nurses is it the doctors
is it Hospital administrators did some
kind of covert government operatives
infiltrate the hospital and sneak around
and the nurses didn't notice and they
they're who is they let family members
in there to make decisions for them I
personally saw when I went to an asthma
clinic that they would not give me
life-saving asthma treatment because
breathing was not allowed even though
they had the Nebulizer breathing was not
allowed
um Candace who didn't allow breathing
and how did you survive if you weren't
allowed to breathe
um and if they had not sent an ambulance
I mean I would asthma attack is about
like you've got a very short window of
time I was having an asthma attack and
the doctor had the life-size medicine
and said that the CDC had barred them
from giving it to me so there was no
question that they colluded to kill
American citizens so that they could
fluff numbers and say that people died
of covid I do I still to this day
question the use of ventilators it makes
entirely no sense people needed oxygen
not compression on their chests when
they were dealing with something that's
in their chest now of course a
ventilator doesn't deprive you of oxygen
um so from top to bottom yes our
government wanted people to die there's
no question now understand that there's
often a conflict with a lot of these
conspiracy theories she says they were
they were killing people to fluff up
Cova death numbers others say the
numbers are just Bogus the numbers are
invented out of thin air and of course
there's a conflict there right because
if the numbers are just invented out of
thin air to make the death seem high why
would you need to go in and kill people
in order for them to be really dead and
reported as coveted deaths because
they're just making up the numbers you
don't need both it's a conflict it
doesn't matter uh because it fed the
narrative yeah and and it's a it's the
we're talking about crimes against
humanity people should face uh long
prison sentences people people should
face tribunals because of what they did
tribunals what are you talking about
during covid
um and it's not even that the masking of
children the treatment of special needs
kids that were being forced to be masked
on planes that were having uh you know
essentially the trauma that was put to
people on a site on a psychological
level uh right he's now speaking to the
emotional trauma yeah he should bring
forth tribunals uh people like Bill
Gates and Dr fauci should be in prison
Rachel Valencia what what what crime did
Bill Gates commit among them this was
corruption top to bottom
and it was all done because they had
already predestined the vaccine right
they did denied treatment they denied
the use of hydroxychloroquine now now
remember
if this was subjected to actual rigor we
would say what evidence do you have that
hydroxychloroquine works for treating
covid and she would either not know or
she would say I don't know there's the
35 person study from France or whatever
and we would say well we have randomized
controlled trials we have really good
random we have proper science and it
shows that it doesn't work now she says
Ivermectin Ivermectin yeah same thing
with Ivermectin what evidence do you
have that Ivermectin works for covet
there is none that is randomized
controlled trials they say it doesn't
work
um but it's it's it's diarrhea of
dishonesty uh the media was complicit in
it and it infuriates me it infuriates me
the amount of people that were allowed
to die and to suffer when there were
medicines that worked because they knew
that they could not get emergency use
authorization if there was all right so
you know you hear stuff like this and
remember people who believe this stuff
sit on juries I've told my story of when
I when I had jury duty on my 21st
birthday and it was appalling it was
appalling that it was a simple
self-defense assault case and a third of
the jury did not even understand the law
it wasn't about we disagree about the
facts it wasn't about we have different
opinions about who's credible a third of
the jury didn't understand the law that
was supposed to be adjudicated
uh used to adjudicate the facts of the
case
so the people who believe oh the
ventilators deprive you of oxygen or
they killed people
these people are on juries they teach
school they might be your dentist they
might be your accountant I don't know
but but more critically you know if
they're your dentist and you don't like
them you get a different dentist you
can't choose your jury
you only to some degree can choose your
kids teachers or whatever the case may
be these people are extraordinarily
dangerous and um they have followers and
it's absolutely horrifying it is a brand
new year maybe you have goals around
getting in better shape maybe cutting
back on sugar that's why you should
check out our long time sponsor magic
spoon magic spoon tastes exactly like
the delicious sweet breakfast cereals
you loved as a kid but magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar 14 grams of protein
and only four net carbs so it's perfect
if you're doing low carb or keto or if
like me you just try to limit your sugar
intake you can build your own variety
pack with flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cinnamon cookies
and cream waffle Maple blueberry that's
my favorite magic spoon lets you enjoy a
sweet delicious snack without the guilt
you can stick to your goals and still
treat yourself and if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do they'll give
you all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to match
spoon.com slash Pacman and use the promo
code Pacman